it's the world's largest active volcano
but maunaloa hasn't looked like this for
almost four decades you know we're way
overdue we were way overdue for model
eruption
um and so
we had prepared
standing at more than 4 000 meters above
sea level Mauna Loa has been stirring
for weeks worrying scientists with
earthquakes just below the summit a sign
of the eruption to come we don't want to
try and second guess the volcano we have
to let it actually show us what it's
going to do and then we inform people of
what is happening ASAP communities had
held emergency meetings in preparation
for a possible evacuation though none so
far has been called I'm here because I'm
concerned I I live here and I work here
Mauna Loa makes up about half the
landmass of the Big Island the
southernmost tip of the Hawaiian
archipelago the U.S Geological Survey
says the eruption is currently contained
to the Volcano Summit about half of
maunaloa's previous eruptions have
stayed there while half have also seeped
out through Rifts at lower elevations
endangering ranches and Beachside
communities we could be in for a little
bit of a prolong time trying to
determine if this is going to be us as a
summit only eruption or a summit plus a
rift Zone eruption residents are fear
fear Mauler neighboring volcano
destroyed 700 homes
maunaloa is both taller and steeper
meaning magma would be able to reach
human populations faster if the mountain
boils over but Hawaii's Emergency
Management agency says that would be a
worst case scenario and one too early to
predict for now it has opened two
shelters as a precaution and warned of
Ash and gases as Hawaiians watch worry
and wait
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera